do you get back to Ireland much is that
I do cause a huge sensation when you go
back it's a Mullingar yeah wanna go yeah
yeah I go home like a couple of times a
year I guess my dad's that lives in the
same spot so I get kind of hectic around
the house the girls have been holes in
the garden and things yeah remember
Robbie Williams once said something to
me he's like my mum closed the curtains
in 92 and never opened them again like
it's good I get to go home and you know
go see the lads and stuff like that and
see the family and it's yeah I like that
side of it but yet Miss Ireland
obviously would like to go there not
morrible and do people kind of do they
look out for you kind of going oh he's
changed or is that all that you have to
be incredibly careful when you go home
sometimes they give in there and you'd
be like as there's kind of like back by
contender you'll be buying like a pint
you know be buying a pint for two or
three lads and then you know the barman
to be gone
Oh someone's doing all right in a nice
doing good just like a few pints yeah
like sometimes if I can go walk at home
right I'll walk home if they're just say
if I go home around Christmas and
there's no taxis and I would start
walking home and then the police will
walk right past me and pick me up bring
me home for a different reason
let's just play funny cuz they catch you
out when you go home don't think this
well I mean there is like like notice
there's this odd thing where people want
to catch out a little bit like you've
got your goal even for breakfast
somewhere or for lunch and I remember I
was actually home this weekend and I was
we went out for you know some eggs and
stuff somewhere I was like oh yeah you
know and I'll have some orange juice and
there they go regardless of what like it
doesn't need to be anything fancy it's
like I and I've like you know an
Americano or it's all like before I left
I used to just bathe in my own
you